so we've talked about this New York
Times poll that shows that in some key
battleground states Donald Trump is
doing way better against Elizabeth
Warren than against Joe Biden or then
against Bernie Sanders and that's all
great and we've already had a discussion
about that but there is another
storyline buried in the polling and it
is about education and it is about race
and it exposes so much of what we've
been saying for the last several years
there are a whole bunch of ways that we
can slice up the polling data for Donald
Trump versus his opponents we can look
by age group we can look by income we
can look at all sorts of things but take
a look at this we're putting up data on
the screen which shows that Donald Trump
is absolutely destroying Biden Bernie
and Warren among voters who were white
without a college education
okay Trump won in 2016 over Hillary by
26 over among voters who are white and
lack a college education Trump is
leading Biden and Bernie by 24 points
each right now among white voters who
didn't go to college
Trump is crushing Warren by even more by
26 among white voters without a college
degree
this is why Republicans don't want to
ish in free College they know the
numbers this is why Republicans aren't
actually doing anything to improve the
circumstances for minority voters
because they are so overwhelmingly not
with them that it probably feels like a
worthless investment of time resources
and money this is not rocket science now
race is a component in the sense that
black voters Hispanic voters other
voters presumably other includes maybe
biracial Asian Native American Trump
gets destroyed in every single one of
those races among those demographic
groups against Biden Bernie and Warren
but when you look at white voters with a
college degree Trump lost in 2016 to
Hillary among that group and Trump is
losing to Biden Bernie and Warren right
now so there is a party that benefits
drastically from keeping people
uneducated what do you think their
policy is going to be to edgy
pation don't teach critical thinking in
middle school in high school
don't make it easier or more affordable
for people to go to college don't do
tuition free college don't provide
student loan relief and that is exactly
what they're doing now there's an
analogy here to voter turnout
Republicans do better when they suppress
voter turnout in elections so what
policies do they want they want to
remove people from voter rolls they want
to increase ID requirements they want to
prevent people from being allowed to
register on the same day of the election
it's totally transparent if you're
paying attention which we have been I
was thinking there's this idea of 1984
versus brave new world these are two
really important dystopian novels 1984
of course by George Orwell brave new
world by Aldous Huxley it's very common
that people will compare or liken what's
happening right now it's a 1984 but the
late Neil postman wrote that very often
when people say something is like 1984
there's a better analogy to brave new
world by Aldous Huxley and I believe
that that's what we're seeing right now
and I'll give you an example Orwell
feared or painted a picture of books
being banned Aldous Huxley feared that
there would be no reason to ban books
and that's the case right now because
you have an entire political movement
the American right-wing movement built
around people who have no real interest
in thinking or in books or in reading or
education or epistemology or critical
thinking they don't need to ban the
books because the people that they're
appealing to aren't reading any books
and like Neil postman said Orwell feared
that the truth would be concealed from
us Huxley feared that the truth would be
drowned out in a sea of irrelevance
Orwell feared we would become a captive
culture Huxley feared we would become a
trivial culture I believe that what we
are seeing right now is much more along
the lines of the picture painted by
Aldous Huxley and brave new world in
this particular sense then by George
Orwell in 1984 it is really scary stuff
and you need only look at the number
to understand where the policy comes
from that we are seeing among the modern
Republican Party disgusting but somehow
we've got to fight it and 2020 and that
election is just the very small first
step it's an important first step but it
is a comparatively small one given what
we're up against